Um,
did you watch the Tom Hanks movie?
I watched 45 minutes at the Tom Hanks movie in Somalia.
In Somalia.
While you were captive?
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
What is that like?
Well,
I,
so I knew that I knew Captain Phillips was going to be a movie when I left.
It was already clear right over.
Had already announced,
announced it when you left and you got to watch it when I'm Somalia.
Yeah,
because by the time,
this is towards the end of my captivity,
I had a short wave radio,
so I was listening to the radio.
By the time it came out and went to the Oscars,
it was all over the BBC.
So I knew about it.
I knew it was out.
I'm like,
okay,
so I'm missing Kevin Phillips,
whatever.
Wonder what that's like.
And then one day,
all the guards got new smart phones,
pretty fancy smartphones,
and they were apparently loaded with a new collection of films and music and
whatever to keep them occupied.
One afternoon I saw two guards just completely wrapped by some sort of film on
the phone.
And I heard some American voices and I'm wondering what this film is.
And finally I said,
fuck me.
That's Tom Hanks.
So I knew what they were watching.
And two weeks later,
one of the guards actually sh he handed me the phone and said,
you know,
Michael,
look.
And so I saw about 45 minutes of it.
Wow.
And of course when he handed me the phone,
the first thing that went through my mind is like,
okay,
I'm going to call mom and find a way to turn down the volume and,
and,
and call California.
Um,
and he took the phone away before I did that,
but I had a whole plan.
I developed a whole plan.
And while I was watching Captain Phillips,
you know,
get on the plane in Boston,
Logan or whatever.
Wow.
It was so atmospherically it was a pretty good,
pretty well done movie.
But there were a couple of scenes.
Where is that where it just wouldn't have happened in real life?
I didn't watch the movie.
Yeah.
So what was a inaccurate about it?
Ah,
there was one scene where there was some selection of pirates on the beach,
so in public,
um,
and I thought,
Gosh,
how did they get that?
That's,
that's,
I've never even heard of that before.
And then I,
then I thought about it and thought and realize,
well that yeah,
actually wouldn't happen like that in public.
That was just for dramatic purposes.
Um,
you know,
I was,
I was envious of their material at first and then every,
that's not,
they made that up.
Um,
so things like that,
but the pirates were fascinated to see people like them and in some cases
they're friends,
um,
portrayed on screen and even though we all know how,
you know,
the movie ends very badly for Somali pirates.
So they knew about the story that was based on,
yeah,
no question.
Not only that,
but one of them said that he was friends with one of the pirates involved and I
believe him actually,
he had the right clan affiliation for that.
So it's,
it's quite possible.
What was it like to see them watching their story being depicted on the other
side of the planet?
Well,
that's what was weird is that they,
they were so fascinated by it,
but we,
you know,
otherwise they didn't look necessarily like to talk about bad news for pirates
or hey,
you know,
like I said,
when the hostages were released or rescued in the first few days of my
captivity,
um,
I kept hearing that the hostages had been killed.
So they like to spin things in a,
in a good way for,
for pirates in general.
So I just would have assumed they would just ignore captain Phillips cause it
ended so badly.
They were just fascinated.
They really were.
And what,
so what was daily life like for you?
Like you,
you ate with them?
Well,
I separately,
but sometimes in the same room.
They,
they made very bad food,
boiled beans and flavorless boiled goat and that kind of thing.
Um,
but they would eat from a communal platter sort of elsewhere within sight.
I didn't have to eat from the same platter as the eat by hand by hand.
Yeah.
That's a very common in that part of the world.
Yeah,
it really is because utensils just aren't,
aren't that common.
And they really liked spaghetti,
so they sort of wrap the spaghetti around your fingers.
And I had done that as a free man.
You know,
I sort of sat with Somalis and ate that way.
But as a,
as a hostage,
I was in no mood to be that,
you know,
that friendly.
Yeah.
They gave me a fork and I could eat my on my own.
So how,
like what kind of physical state where you in after two and a half years of
this?
Yeah,
it was pretty bad.
I was my,
um,
my immune system started to fall apart,
so I don't go into detail too much about this in the book,
but I had a staph infection and my skin and some other kind of infection in my
ear and I was just something in my lungs.
I was just not very,
I was sick.
Um,
and I was sick constantly for several months before I got out.
So I knew something had really changed,
and I think the pirates were aware of that too.
Slowly.
I think they're probably possibly contributed to them lowering your ransom.
Possibly,
but,
but I,
you know,
not that they were sympathetic,
but,
uh,
it's possible they saw me sort of reaching,
reaching my physical limit slowly.
Yeah.
Slowly.